♪ (intro music) ♪
♪ (music) ♪
Flutter has a lot of widgets
to help with explicit animations,
ones that you, the developer, code up.
But there are also widgets
for implicit animations,
those that animate changes for you.
A good one to know
is AnimatedContainer.
You can build it once
with a particular attribute, like color.
And when you rebuild it
with a different value,
say, in response to a setState call,
AnimatedContainer performs
a linear interpolation
between the two values.
And it's more than just colors.
You can animate borders,
border radii, background images,
shadows, gradients, shapes,
padding, width, height,
alignment, transforms, and more.
The length of the animation is controlled
by the duration parameter,
and you can also specify your own curve
to customize the effect.
There are a bunch of other widgets
to help with implicit animations, too.
So head to flutter.io for more info.
♪ (music) ♪